[Music]
oh my
gosh well I have to start with this
happy birthday I know we got the skirt
memo it's your birthday today yes so
what do you do on your birthday do you
do you go all out do you have big plans
I'm kind of a boring lady turns out I'm
a boring lady and today you know the
movie coming out is this is the best
person that's kind of the great gift
could have ever been yes totally I mean
this you were already incredible before
but this is literally I feel like
waitress and just the getting to know
you more as an artist and the scope of
your talent like has blown up your
career in such a different kind of way
like it really is a blessing to have
people like you always had that talent
but to be able to show people like
that's a big gift and it's such a
blessing for a birthday present yeah and
now it's and now it's a movie they're
doing the so it's basically they took
what what it is on stage and then made
it a movie right yes so when we opened
after the after Broadway was closed in
the during the pandemic heard of it
pandemic yeah y world is going great um
yeah so after we um closed we got the
opportunity to reopen and so when we did
it became like a very important um
intention for us to get to you know have
this captured and so it was kind of an
All-Star cast and we we got back on
stage and we took four days and we shot
some with an audience and some that were
just set up so we got to bring the
cameras really close to the action on
stage and um yeah it's very handmade
we've been working really really hard on
this I love that though the is the best
CU you really get in there especially if
you take that time to take those extra
days to really get closeups on people
and really see the emotion it's like
seeing it in a different way it's like
love when they theater you're sort of
spitting to get to the back but in this
you sort of get into the action in a in
a different way and it it came out so
beautiful I'm super proud so I'm super
proud of you that's so cool man you're
just so gifted and just for everybody
that can't get to Broadway I know but
just CU people can't always get here to
see a show so to give them that
opportunity to be a part of the ride cuz
it's such a huge successful hit and it
touches so many people I know I covered
that song and girl I'm telling you what
oh if you think I haven't watched using
that song 3,000 times if you think that
I literally I was like I had to not I
closed my eyes for the entire thing cuz
I hadn't seen we and so I was like I
really didn't know what I was walking
into and that song is so beautiful thank
you oh my God she is to be mine if you
know what I'm talking like it's like the
most amazing
song I literally like I got through it
once and I was proud to get through it
without just completely breaking down
cuz I'm an emotional nutcase but yeah
it's get to know me my cross dear yeah
it's like whatever I'm with you I'm you
this is a great birthday present but I
hear that yours a December baby so near
Christmas right yes so that has to be
kind of hard now my mom was very
intentional about making sure like I
never got birthday paper like I never
got um Christmas paper wrappings you
know like my my birthday gifts were
wrapped in birthday paper and um I
actually love because I love the season
I love this season so much I love that
you know the decorations are out and
we're all like looking forward to New
Year and Christmas and the holidays it's
just like a fresh beginning it always
feels like a fresh beginning that's why
I love Montana so much because it snows
there like all the time snowing right
now and it's just like you get there and
it's like it feels fresh like everything
is new just wet I love it fresh and wet
I love that a little different but yeah
I'll go with it but a look at the movie
of our hit Broadway musical waitress you
can now see it in theaters for a limited
time only so this is a huge thing like I
said a huge like PIV moment in your
career so is it hard to like CU this is
like kind of the book end of it right
the final chapter of it it is there is
something there is something kind of
Bittersweet about it I think there's a
very real knowing that this will be the
last time I'm on stage in that role yeah
which doesn't mean you couldn't go on
stage I do I want to
do I want I do um I think this will be
the last time that I I'm in those shoes
and um I nothing has changed my life in
a more profound way than working on
waitress it really has it's reoriented
everything about me personally
professionally and I just really feel so
grateful to be a part of the story of
the show to carry on the legacy of
Adrienne shell who wrote this beautiful
film is no longer with us but we get to
share this incredible story about
empowerment and learning to love
yourself and um it's just like an
amazing story to be a part of so I I
feel so lucky and it brought me back to
the theater is it it is an Amazing Story
I did see the movie like long long long
ago but I'm saying the music like you
just you forget how powerful it is until
it's done so well that you it moves you
in such a different way like that's and
maybe I'm just biased but but I but I I
am I it's when you go and the songs
really just transport you and all of a
sudden you are just taken somewhere else
the thing that does that I I don't know
any other medium that quite touches it
but music I mean it's our first language
almost you know and it it stirs
something in people's souls and allows
them to feel in a way and I think we as
a global Community we need to be in
touch with our pain and our our
resiliency and um so I think music even
in the musical you know there's a lot of
people out there that are like musicals
yeah not into it no I have friends that
are into that or don't don't do that as
well but when you see it done properly
and like well you're like no that was
executed nicely Yeah it's you're able to
escape I think a lot of people have a
hard time escaping into like all of a
sudden they're singing and dancing like
it's like yeah I'm like be a kid for a
minute try it it's very fun you're you
jaded man you jaded woman I was like
yeah just let it go but I you also have
the waitress to think too because you
met your fiance did I met Joe tippet
yeah and that was in the beginning right
that was in the very beginning yo so
look at that beard game I know he was
shooting a like a western at the time so
his beard was like getting longer and
longer and longer that's awesome you
going to work on that show for a long
time or what do you think oh are you a
person I'm a person that loves it fa I
love I love it to an extent it really
was
like seat on the plane for his beard
when you're at a meal with him and
you're like it's in your beard man yeah
yeah he ni smells like dinner for a
while it's it's like I'm sing last
week's pasta well Sarah posted this on
um her and Joe's 8th anniversary
feelings on wet sponges so very
particular feelings about wet sponges
what's happening there
well what okay so seems in a kitchen
sink there is a sponge generally some
people are Spong but we have a kitchen
sink with a sponge of course and Joe um
really has strong feelings about ringing
out making sure that the sponge is very
very well of course it smells yeah well
I'm the person who's like whatever it's
a sponge like I rung it out I forgot to
ring it out whatever it would drive him
crazy so now I have made myself a little
lamb we gotten like legitimate arguments
about the sponge I'm like
dude it's a sponge like I'm literally
I'm like well we won't have a sponge and
I threw the sponge away and I then I
made myself like a like a homemade
laminated card that says ring out the
sponge Sarah and it's at I wish I took a
picture I would show you the picture I I
mean isn't it hilarious the things that
make us yeah yeah I'm going to be honest
with you I'm 100% with him in that yeah
the
sad smell of sour rag I don't I don't
blame you and the sad realization is the
more I tell this story the more people
are like yeah babe you're wrong we side
we are team Joe yeah so I have to ask
you have new music coming out I'm minute
and I want to hear something it's I'm
working on it I'm working on it it's
kind of slow you have to wait till it
hits so you want to do something really
like it's it's in the like percolating
stage but in fact you know just a few
days ago I was working on something and
um yeah I think it's taken me a long
time to figure out what I wanted to say
about this time like I was a person who
during the pandemic got very quiet and I
knew a lot about artists who like really
went to the pen and paper and like
started generating a lot of music and I
felt like catatonically depressed yeah
and had nothing to say so I think I'm at
you know I'm at a place now where I'm
starting to like process and actually go
through what do I have to say about this
time yeah I think that's important
though I think people always trying to
push stuff out all the time it's like
don't push it like wait till something
like even my last people were like I was
like well I had something to talk about
I was it was like something that was
weighing on me so that's why I think
it's important to wait for that cuz it
it it I don't know it translates better
and people connect better with it when
it's that raw feeling of emotion of
wherever you're at in that chapter of
your life abely CU it's not we don't
live on that cycle you know I it's we're
artists yeah we get to be flighty
exactly that's my
[Music]
[Applause]
excuse thank you guys y'all have a great
night I'm going
home